To find how many fields have missing
values we can do a few things.
Personally, my favorite thing to do when
I bring a file in, is to immediately run
the Field Summary tool on it
to see details about the data.
I'll add the tool in,
add browses to it and run the workflow.
If we look at the interactive output,
we can open the window
from the browser and we can
immediately see that there are missing
values across several fields,
by the red part in this line here.
There are missing data in all of the
fields except for the Client ID field.
If we expand, we can see more
details about the fields.
To actually remove the blank
value record from the data set,
we add a filter tool, and filter where
the value of contact field is not null.
And then we do the same for the industry
and the average number of tickets field.
And then we add one more filter tool for
the last variable,
which is number of employees.
We also need to make sure
that this is not null.
And when we run the workflow, we see
that we have 175 records remaining.
Another way to count the number of
records that come out of the tree side
is to add a tool called count records.
And when we run the workflow,
the number of records passing
through is shown here, 175.
Next, we'll add the scatter
plot tools to the workflow.
One for all of the data,
and the second for
the data with missing values removed.
And then we'll run the results
out to Browse window, and
look at the two scatter
plots side by side.
In looking at the two scatter plots
side by side, we can tell that by
looking at the y axis that the slope
of the line has definitely changed.
The scatter plot on the left
contains all of the data.
And as you can see in the y
axis the slope goes up and
over 100 number of tickets.
Whereas on the right side,
the scatter plot is of the data
with the missing values removed.
We can roughly calculate the slope
of each line from the scatter plots.
With all of the data, we can use
the points along the x axis for
200 and 100 employees.
With 200 employees the average
number of tickets with
all the data is
approximately 22 tickets.
With 1,000 employees, the average
number of tickets is approximately 105.
The slope is equal to the change
in y divided by the change in x.
The slope of the line
is approximately 105
minus 20 divided by a 1,000 minus 200,
or 85 over 800 which is 0.11.
Using the same method for the scatter
plot with the missing values removed.
We can see that the average number
of tickets for 1,000 employees is
approximately 40, and for 200 employees
that number is approximately 25.
Therefore, the slope is equal to 40
minus 25 divided by 1,000 minus 200,
or 15 over 800, which is 0.02.
The slope of the line has
definitely decreased.
Let's see if another imputation method
will be better for our analysis.